so I'm a day one middle-aged guy like
you yes I deal with the younglings yes
and I've got a lot of your commentary on
and I'm finding that saying to them
you're not very skilled so this brain
powers little short
you don't work very hard you know show
up they don't like it when I tell them
that and so the entry party said when
I'm working with them and some of them
have a chance what's your perspective on
dealing with the younglings as a day one
guy how do you get to do stuff without
element they're stupid and lazy i I
actually I actually think of it in
Reverse
I mean most of my 22 and 23 year olds
would look in your face and think that
you're finished and let they [ __ ] you
like money yeah I don't care my money
fall out of the sky they tell me it's
irrelevant but the pleasure it's not
that it's not about cool or what have
you you what you define is money might
be different than the way they define is
money like okay cool how much one you
gonna make for your twenty
three-year-old give me number probably
about forty million bucks for this year
no no not for them Rick doesn't get
forty million dollars how much does Rick
the twenty three-year-old get and give
me the truth because the number isn't
high owner of the company I mean I don't
know if ever I get two three million
bucks compensation this year explain
let's go further I want to know how a
twenty three-year-old gets to the thing
I got a company founder okay right I am
an old-school
web strategy guy I know what works yes
and the email do the best but in the
time every day I want to do that either
resistive it's a communication problem
for me so let me ask you a question yeah
once you just do it for yourself yeah
that's the real question right like cool
if you know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about do for yourself I do I work harder
and I'm smarter than all my 22 year olds
I'm better at social media than
everybody at vaynermedia I'm looking at
them right now just to remind that like
so so honestly I think you're rolling
with like trying to razz them rats
yourself like why are you trying to
funnel through a 23 year old dancer
thank you